[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 économie
qui est cette fois dédié aux cayes
business day qui se déroule au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'est
l'agglomération qui est à l'origine de
cet événement le but est de permettre à
des tpe des pme de rencontrer des grands
comptes lors de rendez vous alors quels
sont les enjeux du sky business day
sommaire focus sur l'entreprise mr bean
cette société de torréfaction est une
pme saint-quentinoise son créneau vendre
du café aux entreprises que sky business
day doit lui permettre de se faire des
contacts et puis nous rencontrerons
aussi jean michel fourgous vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines il est à l'origine
du projet nous verrons avec lui pourquoi
il a mis en place cet événement
et puis nous rencontrerons aussi benoît
galland directeur territorial edf dans
le 78 et nous expliquera en quoi ce type
d'événement est important pour une
grande entreprise comme edf mais tout
d'abord faisons un point sur le sky
business day le sky business day est un
événement qui permet aux grands comptes
et aux pme et aux tpe de pouvoir
échanger 550 entreprises ont répondu à
l'appel il y aura aujourd'hui plus de
3870 rendez vous professionnel parmi les
grands comptes on peut compter mercedes
qui a son siège à montigny le bretonneux
le crédit agricole edf ou encore
hammerson parmi les tpe et pme de
l'agglomération de saint quentin il y
aura entre autres 1616 prod une boîte de
prod de plaisir l'entreprise à rl tibre
npower de guyancourt fils corporate de
voisins-le-bretonneux et à cofor et
mister bean qui nous viennent de
montigny le bretonneux
et d'ailleurs faisons un point sur la
société mister bean cette jeune
entreprise de torréfaction
saint-quentinoise a décidé de tenter sa
chance à cet événement et surtout de
développer son réseau reportage
anne-laure languir
la société mister bean basée à montigny
le bretonneux achètent ces grains de
café en direct à des petits producteurs
et les tories fille dans ses locaux mais
cela n'est qu'une partie de son travail
à dos aussi intégrer ces produits aux
machines à café de ses partenaires c'est
pour cela qu'elle multiplie des prises
de contacts avec les entreprises déjà on
est dans la promo paul dans la promo
paul vous avez à peu près entre 80 et
100 entreprises du territoire
les rencontrer toutes déjà on les a
quasiment toutes rencontrées mais pas
encore tout après en résonne beaucoup
aussi on fait beaucoup partie des
réseaux locaux on participe beaucoup
aussi aux réunions de la maison de
l'entreprise on s'arrange pour vraiment
en moins une fois deux fois par semaine
est dehors être sur les réseaux sur les
différents réseaux du secteur c'est pour
cette raison que le sky business day est
une chance pour la société mister bean
au total 550 entreprises seront
présentes à l'événement participer au
sky business day devrait nous permettre
de rencontrer d'entrer en contact avec
des grands comptes avec lesquels on
n'aurait pas pu entrer autrement nous
permettrait aussi de voir de nouveaux
acteurs de nouveaux partenaires
potentiels le nouveau fournisseur
potentiel et de nouveaux clients
potentiels bien sûr et les grands
comptes sont bien présents au sky
business day comme safran hammerson ou
encore le crédit agricole là société
mister bean espère signer un maximum de
contrats lors de cet événement
et vous avez pu voir que pour les tpe et
les pme le skate business day est un
moment vraiment important mais comment
le projet a vu le jour nous allons en
discuter avec jean michel fourgous vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines bonjour bonjour
alors dites moi pourquoi avoir fait cet
événement bien parce que l'enjeu
dans une agglomération comme
saint-quentin qui est une grosse
agglomération bien sûr c'est d'augmenter
la création de richesses et la création
de richesses et d'emplois et bien c'est
quoi s'est moqué la croissance et
d'entreprises et si vous voulez
augmenter la croissance des entreprises
il faut simplement augmenter leurs
échanges donc dé multiplier les échanges
donc c'est le but de cette journée
aujourd'hui ou avec un partenaire
spécialisé on a donc programmé 3600
rendez vous ce qui est exceptionnel donc
des rendez-vous prospects comme on dit
dans l'entreprise qui va permettre à des
petits et des gros seins des pme de riz
des groupes d'échangés et de plus
travailler ensemble et vous parliez des
petites entreprises c'était une demande
vous avez senti cette demande avant de
construire ce projet de de pouvoir
rencontrer ces gros comptes écoutez moi
j'ai été entrepreneur petit fin j'ai
créé une entreprise de 25 personnes mais
je ne serai que c'est très difficile
d'avoir à rendre des cadrans ronds sont
là aussi
bien sûr que quand vous permettez
aujourd'hui de près 3600 rencontre entre
des petits des gros oui j'aurais rêvé il
s'acquitte m'a dit qu'henry
non non non donc on est content
aujourd'hui de réaliser sa et de
d'éviter ou est-ce qu'on allait nous ne
subit donc c'est on est très contents de
2 700 réunir 700 dirigeants d'entreprise
disponible pour tous nos entrepreneurs
de 50 ha oui je veux venir on est
derrière eux le chiffre est supérieur à
l'objectif qu'on avait fixé c'est bon
signe ça très bien pris alors on y aura
des rendez-vous qui vont se suivre
derrière aujourd'hui il y aurait la
majorité des rendez-vous auront lieu
aujourd'hui mais il ya d'autres
rendez-vous encore qui sont déjà
programmées qui auront lieu dans les
jours qui viennent ne peut être est ce
en plus n'ont pas longtemps de la
méthode ils ont 25 minutes par rendez
vous c'est rapide alors comment on se
prépare en tant que petit tpe et pme
pour
aller mettre toutes les chances de son
côté à écouter c'est un site une
rencontre exceptionnelle c'est un moment
exceptionnel pour les petites
entreprises les gros soucis bien sûr que
si on veut amortir cette journée
bien entendu que il faut mettre un peu
de méthode et 30 minutes vous devez
capable d'avoir un échange et que les
deux parties en 30 minutes de savoir si
le produit que vous vendez et est adapté
aux besoins de l'entreprise ça suffit
tranquille mais et ça oblige bien sûr
nous pouvons trouver à faire un effort
aussi de simplification de de bien
présenter en termes de marketing lors
leur plus concurrentiel et c'est aussi
un entraînement pour eux il améliore
aussi leur marketing donc on est tous
très contents et les uns et les grosses
boîtes en même temps peuvent voir cinq
fournisseurs
oui au lieu d'avoir deux dans le monde
il envoie cinq ou six et en plus de cinq
anciens professionnels où ils se
trouvent et bien sûr merci messieurs
fourgous et je vais aller voir comment
ça se passe du côté des interviews merci
à vous monsieur forte hausse merci alors
de grandes entreprises ont répondu à
l'appel de skype business day comme
hammerson ou encore mercedes benz nous
avons interviewé dans nos studios benoît
galland directeur territorial dans le 78
de zdf et nous lui avons demandé
pourquoi il est important pour une
entreprise comme la sienne d'intervenir
dans ce type d'événement mais en bon
soir monsieur galant pourquoi vous
participez au sky business day d'une
part nous sommes un partenaire
qui sommes aux côtés de
l'agglomération de saint quentin depuis
plusieurs années et d'autre part parce
que
une entreprise telles que edf qui a une
forte sensibilité de service public veut
aussi apporter son expérience et aider
les entreprises de taille moins
importante petites et moyennes
entreprises à travers la différentes
activités économiques nous pouvons
développer c'est le type d'événement que
vous attendez ou de pouvoir rencontrer
comme ça des tpe des pme c'est important
pour vous ce type de manifestation nous
permet de rencontrer en une journée
donnée en un lieu donné un certain
nombre d'entreprises de toute nature de
toute activité et c'est quelque chose
que nous apprécions que nous allons
faire à saint quentin en yvelines il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est une ville
avec une véritable force alors c'est
vrai que la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin regroupe un nombre très
important d'entreprises que ce soient
des grands groupes je pense notamment
crédit agricole mais tout un tissu de
pme tpe et ce type de manifestation me
semble tout à fait adapté à la
configuration économique et
entrepreneuriale du territoire c'est
important ce type d'émulation
émulation entre les entreprises oui nous
on est plutôt là dans l'idée
d'aider d'aider les entreprises à ce
qu'elles puissent concourir aux appels
d'offres que le groupe edf puisse lancer
pour ses activités et donc leur apporter
la possibilité de créer de l'activité
économique et du business et pour ces
tpe et pme c'est une chance pour eux de
pouvoir vous rencontrer à je pense que
pour elle c'est une chance très
importante parce qu'elles vont venir
nous rencontrer on va échanger on va
discuter avec eux on va essayer de leur
donner des informations des indications
je pense que c'est une manifestation qui
est très importante et qui je n'en doute
pas va avoir beaucoup de succès vous
avez une recherche particulière de tpe
pme quand vous allez dans ce genre
d'événements où tout le monde a sa
chance alors tout le monde a sa chance
on est un pour ont fait quasiment tous
les métiers qui existent on est présent
sur de nombreux marchés certes le marché
d'énergie puisque c'est notre activité
première mais on peut très bien
rencontrer des entreprises de coaching
des entreprises événementiel moi j'ai
été sollicité pour comment dirais-je
rencontré un certain nombre
d'entreprises et je suis prêt à
rencontrer toutes les entreprises qui
voient un intérêt de pouvoir échanger
avec un groupe comme edf et dites moi
pour finir comment on fait pour taper
dans l'oeil d'edf ou venir avec un
dossier béton même la petite pme qui a
peut-être juste l'idée ça l'a placé pour
taper dans l'oeil on est soumis à des
règles notamment au niveau de la
communauté européenne
et puis des règles aussi en interne nous
on est prêt à travailler avec tout le
monde
uniquement il faut que les entreprises
répondent à un certain cahier des
charges et notamment qu'une entreprise
soit capable de répondre à un appel
d'offres en conséquence nous sommes une
entreprise très importante et il faut
qu'elle puisse satisfaire nous
satisfaire dans la reste de la réponse
qu'elle qu'elle peut faire il ya des
éléments notamment aussi éventuellement
de développement durable qui sont pris
en considération
donc c'est tous ces éléments tout profit
de la de l'entreprise qui fera qu'elle
pourra être retenu dans un premier temps
et après concourir à nos appels d'offres
dans un deuxième temps et bien je vous
remercie monsieur galore merci à vous
comme je vous le disais il ya plus de
3000 rendez-vous aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être le moment de voir comment
elles se déroulent non alors on a vu un
petit peu votre
entretien ça se passe comment eh bien
écoutez très bien c'est un très bon
moment d'échanger d'apprendre des choses
sur ce qui se passe dans les autres
entreprises et pouvoirs aussi bas avoir
des projets éventuels qui peuvent
déboucher sur du business du coup c'est
est ce que vous aviez prévu pas de
pression pas du tout pas de pression non
non c'est un échange aussi qui est
sympathique on apprend des choses donc
donc voilà donc c'était un rendez vous
vous en aviez besoin
est-ce que vous ressortez satisfaites
ben je ressors satisfaite puisque j'ai
appris des choses sur les incubateurs
donc oui vous allez vous revoir et ben
pourquoi pas sûr non ok très bien je
vous remercie j'ai été très ravi de cet
entretien parce que j'ai rencontré une
entreprise
performante sur notre territoire que je
ne connaissais pas j'ai invité à venir
participer à une réunion d'entrepreneurs
je ne suis pas certaine qu'on ait besoin
de ses services immédiatement mais les
entrepreneurs de notre association ont
de même des clients qui sont des grands
comptes et ils peuvent à l'occasion
donné les coordonnées de cette
entreprise est très sympa de voir une
entreprise qui fait d'un million de
chiffre d'affaires sur notre territoire
et pour finir ça permet quand même de
créer des contacts même si vous l'a
rappelé pas tout de suite oui mais je
lui dis que j'allais la mettre dans la
mailing list qu'elle recevrait les
invitations du club et qu'elle pouvait
venir participer qu'elle aurait
l'occasion de se présenter et de dire ce
qu'elle faisait et moi je trouve aussi
très intéressant que les entrepreneurs
les startups innovantes qui démarre
constate que sur notre territoire on
peut se développer et faire du bon
chiffre d'affaires c'est aussi des
exemples qu'il faut montrer à ceux qui
démarrent et bien je vous remercie alors
maintenant que vous en savez un peu plus
sur le sky business day place à l'agenda
trois dates à noter on commence avec un
atelier développement le thème de ce
rendez vous et comment gérer votre
e-réputation
l'atelier se déroule le 20 octobre
prochain de 9h30 à 12h à la maison de
l'entreprise à montigny le bretonneux et
puis notez aussi que le cadre des
rencontres rh à la maison de
l'entreprise de montigny un atelier sera
mis en place pour mieux comprendre les
questions environnementales et sociales
des acheteurs c'est le 21 octobre de 9
heures à 11 heures à la maison de
l'entreprise à montigny le bretonneux on
passe au rendez-vous création la
thématique de cette rencontre est un
focus sur l'entrepreneuriat des
étudiants ce sera le 26 octobre de 14h30
à 17h à la maison de l'entreprise
montigny cette ut échos c'est fini je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve le 27 octobre pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]